well who thought it was a good idea to
encourage people to use drugs in the
middle of the worst drug epidemic in
American history that's killing more
people than any drug epidemic ever has
and is flipping our society upside down
well Joe Biden thinks it's a good idea
Biden's doj is saying it may soon
legalize what is calling supervised drug
consumption sites all over the country
where people are effectively encouraged
with federal tax dollars to use
narcotics and die
they're going to decide in this in a
matter of weeks Michael schellenberger
is one of the very few reporters in this
country who's actually gone out to take
a look at what this looks like firsthand
these modern opium dens he's the author
of course of San Francisco he joins us
tonight Michael Schumer thank you so
much for coming on so you've reported on
this what do you think of it
well Tucker good to be with you I mean I
think we all saw the Biden family
struggling with Hunter Biden's addiction
and fighting for Hunter Biden's life for
many years any of us who have had
friends or family suffer from drug
addiction we want to fight to rescue
them so they can recover from addiction
what the Biden Administration is
considering doing is legalizing what are
effectively addiction maintenance sites
in the middle of our all of our major
cities not just San Francisco they want
to spread them across the country
naturally they end up getting put in
poor black neighborhoods so you're
looking at two different approaches to
addiction one is fighting for our loved
ones to recover from addiction and
another is to basically give up and give
into addiction to give into the disease
of addiction which I mean every
reputable addiction expert says is the
absolute wrong approach we know that you
need to make an intervention these drug
sites Tucker attract drug dealers
violent drug dealers working for the
Sinaloa cartel and drug users around the
sites that's why San Francisco we got it
shut down after just six months because
it was such a disaster on the street but
the by Administration is actively
considering legalizing these modern
opium dens as one recovering addict
refers to them and making them possibly
opened up in cities across the country
so this is not a new idea there's no
social sciences suggest it works this
happened all across Europe 30 years ago
in Zurich most famously and they were
shut down because it destroyed people so
on what basis are they doing this what's
the motive I don't understand
I mean it is really crazy I mean you
have to remember also there was a very
active effort in the United States to
shut down cigarette smoking we actually
got rid of smoking areas we don't allow
smoking and now they're opening up
Fentanyl and meth smoking areas it's all
victimhood ideology Tucker It's the idea
that people that are addicted to hard
drugs are victims of the capitalist
system and they should just be enabled
in their disease to self-medicate it's a
really twisted philosophy but that's
what we're seeing playing out now at the
federal level
but Marlboros are immoral and at the
same time these same people are telling
us that it's quote dangerous to use a
natural gas stove in your home because
of emissions but they're not concerned
about smoking meth like at some point
you have to wonder like what what's
really going on here I'm wondering that
I don't know
I mean you know you have to consider
that it's part of a broader movement
that thinks that Western Civilization is
a terrible thing that we're founded on
slavery and genocide and so maybe when
they start to do things that undermine
civilization there's a connection there
I I think you're right over the Target
on that you know don't have proof but
what's the other explanation Michael
schellenberger who again has done more
reporting on this than the New York
Times
um and so we're always grateful to have
you on thank you
Good To Be With You Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight